the european union's competitiveness
council aims this month to breathe life
into a new generation of public and
private partnerships
that will help create jobs and boost
economic growth
the partnerships will contribute to the
launch of large-scale and long-term
innovation projects
under the eu's massive new research
program horizon 2020
they'll focus on innovative medicine
more effective diagnostics and
treatments
with the aim of improving the health and
well-being of europeans
other partnerships include bio-based
industries aeronautics
electronics fuel cells and hydrogen the
european commission estimates that the
projects could draw
17 billion euros in investment in public
debate the council will seek a general
political approach
on the european program for monitoring
the earth from satellites
known as copernicus the program will be
used to support the agriculture and
fisheries sectors
and will help in disaster response work
including fighting forest fires
elsewhere on the agenda ministers will
try to reach a common position
concerning new rules on breaches of
anti-trust laws
which has happened in the car industry
among other sectors
the proposals could make it easier for
victims of cartels
to receive compensation for loss of
business and
lost profits